erneuerbare Energien sind unsere Zukunft
darüber ist sich der löwenan Teil von
Politik und Wissenschaft sicher und das
Potenzial von erneuerbaren Energien ist
riesengroß theoretisch lässt sich aus
Sonne Wind Biomasse Wasser und Erdwärme
tausendfach mehr Energie gewinnen als
wir Menschen eigentlich brauchen die
Erneuerbaren sind nicht nur wichtig im
Kampf gegen den Klimawandel sondern auch
eine große Chance uns unabhängiger zu
machen damit wir nicht mehr auf Gas und
Öl aus Ländern wie Russland und
Saudi-Arabien angewiesen sind trotz
vieler Vorteile gibt es aber auch
Menschen die die Windkraft klar ablehnen
oder zumindest Kritik daran äußern auch
aus der Politik manchmal werden auch
ziemlich weirde Thesen verbreitet immer
wieder tauchen auch solche Schlagzahlen
auf Infraschall die unsichtbare Gefahr
der
Windkraftanlagen sterben Vögel durch
Windräder alarmierende Studie
Klimaerwärmung durch Windräder das sind
natürlich krasse Thesen die Zweifel
wecken können kein Wunder also dass
teilweise auch ziemlich viel gegen
Windkraft protestiert wird z.B mit
solchen Plakaten hier aber was ist an
den ganzen Sorgen dran und woher kommen
sie in diesem Video checken wir ob
Windkraft wirklich gefährlich für
Menschen Klima und Umwelt sein kann oder
ob das alles nur Panikmache ist
willkommen beim ZDF background
Check es muss sich etwas ändern und zwar
schnell das merken wir spätestens
seitdem der energieimport aus Russland
massiv reduziert wurde und die
Energiekosten und Benzinpreise letzten
Winter explodiert sind auf erneuerbare
Energien können wir nicht mehr
verzichten und nicht nur was die
Versorgungssicherheit betrifft
Expertinnen und Experten sind sich
ziemlich einig erneuerbare sind
unverzichtbar um das 1,5° Ziel noch
ansatzweise zu packen deshalb wird der
Ausbau von erneuerbaren Energien stark
vorangetrieben mittlerweile stehen in
Deutschland ungefähr 30.000
Windkraftanlagen im ersten Halbjahr 2023
lag der Anteil von Windenergie über dem
von Kohle damit war sie die wichtigste
Stromquelle bei der Stromerzeugung durch
Windkraft wird 0 Co 2 produziert auch
wenn bei der Herstellung der Anlagen
selbst CO2 entsteht ist das immer noch
nur ein Bruchteil der kohlendioxidmengen
die Gas und Kohlekraftwerke im Betrieb
ausstoßen das heißt jede Windkraftanlage
die einen fossilen Energieträger ersetzt
spart CO2 bei modernen Anlagen sind es
pro Windrad bis zu 10.000 Tonnen im Jahr
in 2022 wurden durch Windkraftanlagen
insgesamt ca 55 Millionen Tonnen CO2
eingespart das war fast ein Sechstel des
gesamten deutschen aussto es in dem Jahr
windkraft ist also ein wichtiger Teil
der Energiewende aber sie hat auch viele
Gegnerinnen und Gegner einige
kritisieren z.B die Effizienz oder auch
die Entsorgung und das Recycling der
Rotorblätter aber manche sorgen sich
auch um ihre Gesundheit ist da wirklich
was dran schuld daran soll das
sogenannte wind turbine Syndrome sein
das ist ein Phänomen das
unterschiedliche Symptome beschreibt von
denen Anwohnerinnen und Anwohner in der
Nähe von Windkraftanlagen sprechen dazu
gehören z.B Herzrhythmusstörung
Kopfschmerzen Schwindel oder
Schlafstörung das soll an Infraschall
liegen der von den Windkraftanlagen
ausgeht Infraschall sind Schallwellen in
einem Bereich den wir Menschen nicht
hören können also unter 20 Herz die ein
Herz gibt die Schwingung des Schalls pro
Sekunde an er entsteht z.B in der
Industrie im Verkehr aber auch in der
Natur durch windböhnen und eben auch
durch Windkraftanlagen im Gegensatz zu
hörbarem Schall gibt's zu Infraschall
relativ wenige Untersuchung super lange
hat man sich deshalb nur auf einen
bestimmten Bericht gestützt und zwar der
Bundesanstalt für Geowissenschaften und
Rohstoffe der wurde 2005 veröffentlicht
und darin wurden sehr sehr hohe
infraschallwerte für Windräder angegeben
und zwar um die 100 Dezibel Dezibel
geben den sogenannten Schalldruckpegel
an also die Intensität von Schall wenn
die Schallintensität bei Infraschall
besonders hoch ist wird er auch von uns
Menschen wahrnehmbar die Studie von BGR
wurde von Anfang an in Expertenkreisen
ziemlich kritisch betrachtet unter
anderem weil andere Messungen in in der
Regel nur auf um die 60 Dezibel gekommen
sind an der Stelle ist noch wichtig wenn
man direkt unter einem Windrad steht
kann die Belastung natürlich höher sein
die Werte beziehen sich auf den Umkreis
ab 80 m Entfernung
2021 hat die Bundesanstalt für
Geowissenschaften und Rohstoffe dann
einen ziemlich großen Messfehler
eingeräumt durch diesen Fehler waren die
Angaben 36 debel zu hoch klingt jetzt
vielleicht erstmal gar nicht so krass
aber die dezibelskala und somit auch die
Schalleistung steigt exponentiell an 36
Dezibel entsprechend einer Steigerung um
den Faktor 4000 der Wissenschaftler
Stefan Holzheu der den Rechenfehler
entdeckt hat spricht von einem groben
wissenschaftlichen Fehler und auch der
damalige Bundeswirtschaftsminister Peter
Altmeier hat sich dafür ganz öffentlich
entschuldigt er sprach damals selbst
davon dass Welten zwischen den
bgrwererten und der Realität liegen und
diese Welten sind in dem Fall ziemlich
entscheidend ab 100 Dezibel kann es
nämlich zu körperlichen Auswirkungen
kommen die Grenze kann hier zwar etwas
variieren weil jeder Mensch anders
reagiert aber trotzdem ist ab solchen
Werten Vorsicht geboten mittlerweile
haben Forschungsgruppen die Auswirkung
mal genauer gecheckt z.B wurden in einer
Studie 38 Testpersonen über einen Monat
hinweg mit einem schallgerät
ausgestattet manche haben echte
infraschallgeräte bekommen andere nur
Attrappen wer welches Gerät bekommt
wurde aber nicht kommuniziert am Ende
konnten bei keiner der Testgruppen
Auswirkung auf das her kreisaufsystem
den Schlaf oder die mentale Gesundheit
festgestellt werden man muss an der
Stelle aber einschieben dass es noch
keine Langzeitstudien zu der Belastung
gibt aktuell gibt's aber keine
Ergebnisse die bestätigen dass
Windkraftanlagen ein reales
Gesundheitsrisiko sind an der Stelle
kommt dann der notzebo Effekt ins Spiel
ja richtig gehört nicht plbo notzebo
quasi der Bruder des placeboeffekts aber
auf jeden Fall das schwarze Schaf der
Familie nozebo lässt sich aus dem
Lateinischen übersetzen und zwar mit ich
werde Schaden Menschen bei denen der
Effekt auftritt entwickeln ihre Symptome
erst durch den Glauben daran dass etwas
schädlich ist sowas kann auch bei
Medikamenten passieren z.B gab es
folgenden Fall eine Person hat im Rahmen
einer Studie nur placebomittel bekommen
ist aber mit einer vermeintlichen
Überdosis ins Krankenhaus gekommen und
zwar zitternd und mit super niedrigem
Blutdruck als die Person dann erfahren
hat dass sie nur ein Scheinmedikament
bekommen hat waren die Symptome sehr
schnell wieder weg genau der Effekt soll
eben auch bei Wind KfT auftreten man
konnte bei Betroffenen zwei körperliche
Symptome feststellen aber eben keine
organischen Gründe das legt zumindest
die Annahmen nahe dass die Symptome
psychosomatisch sind also es weiß
erstmal nichts darauf hin dass Windräder
wirklich krank machen die
langzeitauswirkung von Infraschall
müssen aber noch genauer untersucht
werden manche Menschen die Windkraft
ablehnen behaupten nicht nur dass
Windkraftanlagen krank machen Windräder
sollen angeblich sogar klimaschädlich
sein das wird immer wieder auf Social
Media behauptet und unter anderem von
der AFD Schul soll ein bestimmtes
Treibhausgas sein und zwar
Schwefelhexafluorid abgekürzt als SF6
und ja das schon mal vorab das Gas ist
ziemlich klimaschädlich SF6 hat von
allen Gasen die man so kennt sogar die
höchste Treibhauswirkung die Zahlen
schwanken hier ein bisschen aber die
Wirkung soll ca 25 000 Mal stärker sein
als bei Kohlendioxid und damit es nicht
zu verwirrend wird CO2 wird als
Richtwert für die Treibhauswirkung
benutzt weil es weltweit den größten
Anteil am Treibhauseffekt hat das heißt
man rechnet immer in CO2 äquivalente um
um den Effekt aufs Klima anzugeben SF6
ist aber nicht nur extrem klimaschädlich
wenn es einmal inent weicht bleibt es
auch bis zu
3200 Jahre in der Atmosphäre das ist
tatsächlich ein Problem aber eins das
auch schon sehr lange bekannt ist schon
1997 wurde im Kyoto Protokoll eine
Grenze für das Gas festgelegt allerdings
ist es in der Industrie super beliebt
weil es sehr gute elektrische
Eigenschaften hat hat das wird z.B
genutzt um elektrische Leitung zu
isolieren weil es kaum mit anderen
Stoffen reagiert unter anderem setzt man
es eben in den Schaltanlagen von
Windrädern ein um die festgelegten
Grenzwerte einzuhalten wurde in der
Industrie beschlossen das Gas nur noch
in geschlossenen Systemen bzwise
Kreisläufen zu benutzen also das Gas
bleibt konstant in den Anlagen außerdem
wird beim Befüllen bei der Nutzung und
auch beim Recycling der Anlagen sehr
stark darauf geachtet dass das Gas nicht
entweicht aber natürlich gibt's immer
ein gewisses Rest Risiko deshalb ist die
Industrie verpflichtet regelmäßig zu
prüfen wie viel Gas in die Atmosphäre
austritt und nach eigenen Angaben wurden
die Werte bisher immer eingehalten aber
auch unabhängige Institutionen wie das
Umweltbundesamt haben das ganze
natürlich mal gecheckt und ich sag mal
so dass es in dem Fall für die Industrie
etwas in die Hose gegangen Auswertung
vom Umweltbundesamt haben nämlich
ergeben dass die Angaben der Industrie
nicht stimmen können denn die
Konzentration von SF6 in der Atmosphäre
späre ist wohl höher als gedacht und hat
in Deutschland einen stärkeren
Treibhauseffekt als der innerdeutsche
Flugverkehr Deutschland ist im übrigen
der größte SF6 Emittent in Europa aber
nicht falsch verstehen das bezieht sich
nicht nur auf die Windkraft sondern auf
die gesamte Industrie SF6 wird in sehr
vielen Bereichen genutzt es wird nicht
nur in windkraftschaltanlagen verbaut
sondern z.B auch bei solarkraftanlagen
Kohle oder Atomkraftwerken und in ganz
verschiedenen elektronischen Geräten
besonders viel SF6 wird aber heute noch
durch Schallschutzfenster ausgestoßen
bei denen darf SF6 zwar schon seit 2006
nicht mehr verbaut werden aber trotzdem
gibt es halt noch viele die übrig sind
und durch die das Gas weiter Austritt
der Ausschuss von SF6 durch Windkraft
ist dem Umweltbundesamt nach dafür sehr
gering denn die modernen Schaltanlagen
von Windrädern sind nicht sehr anfällig
für Lex bei sachgerechter Wartung und
Entsorgung liegt das Risiko dass
überhaupt Gasaustritt bei unter
0,5%. im Normalbetrieb in weichen pro
Anlage nur 0
0,0705 Tonnen CO2 quivalente im Jahr die
voraussichtliche Belastung ist hier also
minimal abgesehen davon sind die
Einsparpotentiale von CO2 durch
Windräder so hoch dass sie auch mit
einer höheren SF6 Belastung einen
positiven Effekt auf das Klima hätten
obwohl das Risiko eher gering ist hat
die EU das Problem trotzdem auf dem
Schirm und hat deshalb festgelegt dass
ab 2030 kein SF6 mehr in Schaltanlagen
eingesetzt werden darf so das haben wir
schon mal geklärt es gibt aber noch
andere Behauptung die sich direkt auf
die Aktivität von Windrädern beziehen
angeblich sollen Windräder auch zu mehr
dürren führen und das Klima Aufheizen
auch das ist ein Gerücht das immer
wieder in den Medien verbreitet wird sei
es von Privatpersonen oder durch
scherpix der AFD die dürren sollen an
manchen Orten entstehen weil Windräder
angeblich weiterziehende Wolken stoppen
dadurch soll es dann eben in manchen
Gebieten nicht regnen und das soll z.B
in Südeuropa zu mehr Waldbränden führen
das klingt ziemlich absurd Windräder
sind nicht in der Lage Wolken zu
beeinflussen man kann fast eher sagen es
ist anders herum bei sogenannten
Tiefdruckgebieten ist das Wetter in der
Regel schlechter Wolken Zehen auf es
regnet und es wird windig das heißt auch
Windräder lieben Tiefdruckgebiete und
sie kommen eben vor allem in Schwung
wenn Wolken am Himmel sind aber sie
bremsen sie nicht aus also dass
Windräder Wolken aufhalten und es
dadurch an einigen Orten nicht regnet
und Dürren entstehen ist ganz klar
falsch eine andere Behauptung die an
diesen Mythos anknüpft ist die dass
Windräder das globale Klima Aufheizen
angeblich sollen Windräder nämlich die
Luft erwerben und dadurch eben auch das
Klima auch hier kann ich schon
vorwegnehmen das ist ebenfalls
ziemlicher Quatsch was allerdings stimmt
ist dass Windräder das sogenannte
Mikroklima beeinflussen können je nach
Luftverteilung ist die Luft z.B unten am
Boden kälter und feuchter und dafür
weiter oben in den Luftschichten etwas
wärmer und Trockner wenn dort jetzt ein
Windrad aktiv ist durchmischt es die
Luftmasse die Luft wird von oben nach
unten gedrückt und andersherum und
dadurch ändern sich auch die
Feuchtigkeit und Wärme in den jeweiligen
Schichten also ja Windräder können das
Mikroklima beeinflussen auf das globale
Klima haben sie allerdings keinen
Einfluss und sie lösen auch keine
trockenwellen aus das heißt das
windreder eigentlich nicht gut sondern
schlecht für unser Klima sind können wir
definitiv ausschließen windrder sollen
manchen Leuten nach aber nicht nur eine
Gefahr für uns Menschen selbst und das
Klima sein sondern auch für Flugtiere
Kritikerinnen und Kritiker behaupten
nämlich dass Windräder für ein
Massensterben von Vögeln verantwortlich
sind dazu gibt's häufig auch heftige
Diskussionen auf Social Media Plattform
und auch der NABU der Naturschutzbund
hat sich in der Vergangenheit kritisch
geäußert zusammen mit einigen Vogel und
Naturschutzorganisationen hat das
schwedische Energieunternehmen
wattenfall deshalb eine neue Studie mit
offshore winterlagen durchgeführt über
ein halbes Jahr wurden da Küstenvögel
getrackt und über 10 000 Videos
aufgezeichnet in dem Zeitraum gab es
tatsächlich keinen einzigen Zusammenstoß
zwischen Vögeln und windr Räder in der
Studie haben die Forschenden nämlich
festgestellt dass fast alle Vogelarten
ihre flugruten einfach angepasst haben
und zwischen den Windrädern
hindurchgeflogen sind das sind erstmal
good news aber Achtung das heißt jetzt
auch nicht dass Windräder gar keine
Gefahr für Vögel darstellen ich stehen
ja nicht alle Windkraftanlagen offshore
sondern auch viele an Land andere
Studien kommen darauf dass Vögel in der
Nähe von Windkraftanlagen ein 50%
höheres Sterberisiko haben von einem
Massensterben zu sprechen ist aber noch
ziemlich übertrieben mal zum Vergleich
pro Jahr sterben ca 100.000 Vögel durch
Windkraftanlagen durch Glasscheiben sind
es ca 1000 mal mehr und auch durch
Katzen sind es ungefähr 600 Mal so viele
ja Windräder sind eine Gefahr für manche
Flugtiere aber sie führen nicht zu einer
Art massensterbende Tiere es gibt aber
andere Flugtiere die gefährdeter sind
Fledermäuse pro Jahr sterben so zwischen
200.000 und 300 000 Fledermäuse durch
Windräder vor allem wenn die Anlagen im
Wald aufgestellt werden ist das für die
Tiere ein Problem
aber warum sind Windräder für
Fledermäuse so gefährlich es gibt
unterschiedliche Gründe warum die Tiere
zu Schaden kommen und Sterben entweder
sie kollidieren mit den Rotorblättern
oder sie leiden unter dem sogenannten
Barotrauma beim Barotrauma platzen die
Lungen und die inneren Organe der
Fledermäuse und zwar weil es durch die
Windräder zu luftdruckveränderung kommt
abgesehen davon verkleinert sich aber
auch ihr Lebensraum wenn Windräder in
welern aufgestellt werden zwar gibt es
Aufforstung aber die reichen oft noch
nicht aus deshalb wird z.B versucht den
von Windrädern an das Flugverhalten der
Tiere anzupassen manche Windräder werden
also z.B zu ihren Flugzeiten
ausgeschaltet außerdem müssen
Ausgleichsflächen für die Tiere
geschaffen werden nicht nur für
Fledermäuse sondern eben auch für Vögel
seit Juli 2022 gibt's dafür auch eine
Änderung im
Bundesnaturschutzgesetz durch die
artenhilfsprogramme gefördert werden
sollen es gibt also in manchen Bereichen
noch Handlungsbedarf Windkraft deshalb
zu verteufeln ist aber Quatsch lass un
mal zusammenfassen die Mythen die zu
Windkraft kursieren sind zum großen Teil
über trieben oder basieren auf falschen
Fakten oder falschen Interpretationen
für die argumentationsart der Windkraft
Gegnerinnen und Gegner gibt es einen
Namen ungenaue Induktion das ist eine
Art der wissenschaftsleugnung dabei
werden Teilaspekte auf das gesamte
Phänomen übertragen oder aus
Einzelheiten und bestimmten
Beobachtungen werden bewusst falsche
Schlüsse gezogen so wird eine
Wissenschaftlichkeit vorgetäuscht die
die Glaubwürdigkeit von Leuten die gegen
Windkraft Position beziehen stärken soll
und das spielt bestimmten Gruppierung in
die Karten zum auch dem Eike Institut
Eike steht für europäische Institution
für Klima und Energie das ist ein
eingetragener Verein der vor allem eins
macht den Klimawandel leugnen das
Institut bezeichnet Klimawissenschaft
als Mittel der politischen
Instrumentalisierung und zwar um
Veränderung in der Energiepolitik
voranzutreiben und na ja um damit Geld
zu machen angeblich soll das alles nur
eine Methode sein um den Profiteuren
unter anderem Steuergelder in den Rachen
zu werfen auf der Institutsseite wird
hier von der Chimäre Klimawandel
gesprochen mal kurz Einordnung die
Chimäre ist ein Fabelwesen aus der
griechischen Mythologie im Prinzip wird
hier also der Klimawandel zum Mythos
degradiert auch wenn man meinen sollte
dass man es nicht mehr betonen muss der
Mensch gemachte Klimawandel ist in der
seriösen Wissenschaft nicht umstritten
aber was haben denn die Leute davon den
Klimawandel zu leugnen häufig sind es
Menschen oder Konzerne mit einer
politischen oder wirtschaftlichen Agenda
die versuchen den Klimawandel zu
relativieren z.B Vertreterinnen und
Vertreter der Öl und Kohlewirtschaft die
kein Interesse daran haben dass fossile
Energien ersetzt werden um die eigenen
wirtschaftlichen Interessen zu schützen
werden aus diesen Kreisen
Fehlinformationen über das Klima
verbreitet schon 1965 hat ein
Expertenbericht aus den USA ein Anstieg
der CO2 Emissionen von 25% bis ins Jahr
2000 vorausgesagt und eben auch dass es
dadurch schädliche Klimaveränderung
geben wird und spätestens seit Anfang
der 90er Jahre wusste man dann durch
einen Bericht des Weltklimarats dass die
globale Erderwärmung Realität ist
seitdem versuchen fossile
Energiekonzerne massive Zweifel zu sehen
und betreiben richtige abwehrkampagnen
gegen den Klimaschutz 1998 wurde sogar
ein Strategieplan vom American Petroleum
Institut gelegt der genau das beweist
unter anderem auch dass Fachleute
gekauft wurden um Fehlinformation zu
verbreiten Konzerne wie BP Shell oder
total sollen 200 Millionen Dollar
jährlich für Lobbyarbeit gegen
Klimaschutz ausgegeben haben und auch
Russland oder Saudi-Arabien die ja
extrem von Erdöl oder erdgasexporten
profitieren versuchen immer wieder die
Auswirkung fossiler Energien zu
relativieren Putin hat noch vor ein paar
Jahren behauptet die Erderwärmung stehe
durch kosmische Veränderung und bei
einigen Leuten fällt diese
Desinformation auf fruchtbaren Boden
Grund dafür ist Fachleuten nach häufig
Angst wo Angst herrscht ist Leugnung
manchmal die leichtere Alternative wie
sieht es den bei euch aus was haltet ihr
von Windkraft und kennt ihr Leute die
sich ganz klar gegen sie aussprechen
oder sich für gefährlich halten schreibt
mal in die Kommentare und auch wenn euch
andere Mythen oder
verschwörungserzählung interessieren die
wir ich immer checken sollen in unserem
letzten background Check Video ging es
übrigens um die Erzählung vom großen
Austausch und was sie so gefährlich
macht falls euch das interessiert findet
das Video hier und vergesst auch nicht
den Kanal zu
abonnieren